Walter is on the line in Houston hey
Walter how are you are you better than I
deserve what's up all right they just
want to kind of give you an aerial
background I have probably about I say
roughly about 27,000 in car long did
about 10,000 or 11,000 that student loan
debt and about well over ten thousand
and a credit card and personal loans
debt and I'm currently engaged and we're
planning a wedding and I just want to
kind of know where do I get started from
here as far as making sure you know I do
the right thing by my bride-to-be and
making sure also you know be responsible
like I haven't been in the past
mm-hmm okay good good does she have any
debt yes she does how much about 14,000
homes on a vehicle and she has about 130
and student loan debt Oh doctor or
lawyer no she's uh she's an educator a
teacher mm-hmm $130,000 to be a teacher
wallet yeah she she went and got a
master's degree well you can get a
master's degree a lot cheaper than a
hundred and thirty thousand dollars for
me that was before we met Dave yeah well
I mean you don't need dave to figure
that out okay
Wow and so what does she make a year oh
well she she wasn't in the education she
wasn't a classroom last year this year
she came out because it was it was
really stressful for her and she
probably old man she probably makes
about 2425 a year it was stressful yet
they're like $130,000 isn't oh yeah what
was she making when she was stressed she
was making about 50 our predict stress
will be back in her life okay it's time
for her to go back to the classroom
until she cleans up the mess she's made
with your help
that's called stress when you make a
hundred and thirty thousand dollar
decision to get a master's degree in
teaching and you can teach 450 you don't
go make 24 I'm sorry you'll be stressed
now what do you make 130 Wow great
that's the best news in this whole
conversation what do you do I'm a worker
good for you okay cool all right so
when's the wedding it's actually January
of 2019 why so long to be able to make
sure we save up and not about going to
get for it cash flow everything okay
well I mean if you're sitting on a
hundred eighty thousand dollars between
the two of you income because she's back
in the classroom you can save up a ten
thousand dollar wedding pretty quick
okay because I'm taking you have to pay
for the wedding
mom offered to pay for the venue which
is pretty much the most expensive part
cool well let's do it this spring then
and you know save up some money right
quick and do that and then and then what
I'm soon as you're married what I'm
gonna do is live
all of these debts smallest to largest
pay minimum payments on everything but
the little one and attack the little one
with a vengeance and then and then as
soon as it's gone then you work your way
right down this list the good news is if
she goes back in the classroom you guys
have a one hundred eighty two hundred
thousand dollar income somewhere in
there you can clean this mess up within
a few years and then she can quit and do
whatever she wants to do I don't care I
don't care if she wastes her education
that's up to her but the but but but in
the meantime she doesn't have that
economic option because she made a
hundred and thirty thousand dollar
choice to go into debt and so you guys
have got to create as much possible
income as you can in this household
because you've got a couple hundred
thousand dollars in consumer debt laying
around and it's going to take you two
years three years a blistering work to
pull that together if both of you are
maximizing your incomes and that's what
you want to do starting now ready set go
I'll help you we'll put you through
Financial Peace University as our
wedding gift to you so I've moved the
wedding up and I'd get married like in
March for ten thousand bucks and pay
cash for it and then let's get on with
it here and let's clean this mess up
both of you and lean into it the good
news is the interesting thing about the
classroom is once it has a reason when
she has a reason to go over there
because you're working this plan
together it won't be as stressful it'll
be easier because it's helpful if you
have a reason for doing something it
gives you a way to work through whatever
is stressful in the classroom so hold on
Kelly will pick up and we will give you
a Financial Peace University as our
wedding gift we want you to go through
the nine week class and then we'll help
you with this as you go along dude but
you could turn this around but y'all are
gonna have to make very careful smart
decisions both of you in order to
address the mess that the two of you
have made it's not just you it's her too